now to the june unemployment picture
president biden is choosing to focus on
the positive but there is more to the
story
white house correspondent peter ducey
looks at the facts and figures for us
tonight good evening peter good evening
shannon the jobs number 850 000 in may
beat expectations and while some of the
experts around here say
it's just one set of numbers they are
more interested in watching the trends
the president is ready to call his
economic
plan a historic success
the last time the economy grew at this
rate was in 1984
and ronald reagan was telling us it's
morning in america
well it's getting close to afternoon
here but as many states continue
offering 300
a week and extra unemployment benefits
9.3 million job openings remain
a record there's nobody coming in for a
job
we're in need for from a bus person
dishwasher
prep people uh cook
pizza guy just no one comes in for work
anymore that's okay for now according to
the labor secretary
yeah there's still job openings to fill
but this uh this report was a good solid
report
we're excited it shows that president
biden's economic plan is working
republican congressman kevin brady warns
president biden has quickly fallen 679
000 jobs short
of the projections for his jobs plan
workers are still staying on the
sidelines and while wages are
going up prices are going up faster but
the president says
this is post-pandemic progress put
simply
our economy is on the move and we have
covert 19 on the run
the white house's vaccination goal 70
percent of adults by this weekend
will be missed but celebrations are okay
you're going to be able to be with your
families
and backyard barbecues as we hoped on
the cheap
according to the white house where the
twitter account boasts the cost of a
fourth of july cookout in 2021 is
down 16 cents from last year so does the
white house think that 16 cents off a
barbecue
has more of an impact on people's lives
i would say if you don't like hot dogs
you may not care of the reduction of
costs
you don't have to like hot dogs
i will say that what we are most focused
on is the fact that we've created now
more than three million jobs since the
president took office
so regarding the economy the white house
thinks they're on a
roll and on the subject of hot dogs
there my line of questioning was not
intended to be a
grilling i was just trying to be frank
shannon you did not okay listen maybe we
can pull our 32 cents together and then
you can have a couple bites of hot dog
to enjoy this weekend but before we get
to that peter um what are we learning
now about
joe biden possibly meeting with hunter
biden's business partners we're talking
about when the president back when he
was vice president
so have a look we've got a picture of a
2015
email and when you start looking at the
timestamps on there uh this was
pulled off of that infamously left
behind laptop it appears to show hunter
biden trying to arrange a coffee meeting
at the naval observatory that is where
the vice president lives and this photo
from around the same time that you'll
see next shows the former vice president
with
his son hunter the mexican billionaire
carlos slim and several
other hunter biden business associates
so this image could challenge the white
house's
long-standing assertion that uh
that basically has been the same thing
for two full years since the president
told it to me in
iowa uh he insists and they insist that
he has never spoken to his son
about his overseas business dealings
shannon
all right peter enjoy that cookout this
weekend thank you very much from the
white house